president biden doesn't make you feel
safe no no he doesn't nor does uh the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general miley you know i think we've got
one of the least competent
and most dangerous administrations
where nuclear war is concerned that that
we've ever had
you know they they genuinely believe
that a nuclear war cannot be
won and must never be fought
and uh that's patently untrue
uh but it emboldens them to take risks
that previous more responsible
administrations would not take
you know i think their whole ukraine
policy is based on the fact that there's
a lot of people in the bible
administration really think oh putin
agrees with us that a nuclear war cannot
be fought and it cannot be won and must
never be fought and therefore we can we
can
go as far as we want in ukraine we can
push ukr
putin out of power and and prevail over
russia at a conventional level in
ukraine and we won't have to worry about
a nuclear war because putin isn't crazy
and he understands that a nuclear war
cannot be won and must never be fought
that is false that's a very dangerous
assumption but the people in charge of
us now in charge of our national
security actually believe that
what did uh the previous administration
under president trump how did you feel
about you said you don't feel very safe
under biden or general milly
under
trump and his his administration did you
feel any different oh yeah i i felt a
lot uh a lot more safe
uh
uh you know if only because of trump's
personality uh you know he was no fool
uh he didn't say things like you know
nuclear war cannot be
won and must never be fought
uh his uh
nonetheless even under president trump
uh okay the president would make certain
claims that weren't true
uh such as what well for example that
america uh that our military has never
been stronger and we're better prepared
now than we ever have been that's not
true because he had been increasing
defense budgets it takes a long time uh
on president trump was doing the right
things i mean he was investing money in
in modernizing our nuclear triad okay
but under president trump uh uh you know
one would get the impression that we
spent all this defense money that
therefore our triad was stronger and
better
it wasn't you know uh
all of the
all of the nuclear submarines and
bombers and missiles and all of the
warheads on all of those systems
are 30 40 years old they go back to the
reagan administration and president
trump
didn't change that
you know it's going to take a long time
to modernize the triad
it's and we're not going to get
new systems coming online until a decade
from now into the 2030s okay
now i'm not criticizing president trump
for making those statements i think as
the president
it was important for him to make those
statements because nuclear deterrence in
a lot of ways is based on a big bluff
you know uh you know uh by him saying
things like that and asserting that and
threatening our adversaries
uh they didn't know what to make of him
i actually think that his personality
that strong patriotic personality that
potential unpredictability that's what
the word i was able to say yeah you know
unpredictability yeah that's powerful
deterred them okay some some people
might call it um erratic though
well
when you know when you're facing a
situation where the adversary has all
these advantages
you know uh anything that deters them
and makes them
pause uh you know is a good thing
including
that erratic behavior if he's
unpredictable aka erratic you know
interchangeable interchangeable in some
capacity regardless
the enemy doesn't know what to make of
it is that what you're saying the enemy
could uh you know would have
the enemy would not was not confident i
think under president trump that this
guy might not himself launch a nuclear
first strike if he thought that america
was endangered
one could easily see president trump
doing anything necessary to defend the
united states including striking first
and that scared them so
so that they
they were
more that's why they didn't invade
ukraine so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]